Chicken Little was a wee little hen...
...who was known around the kingdom for her good advice.
All the animals would come to her with their problems.
Gus van Goose would ask Chicken Little about his stories...
...when he couldn't come up with a good ending.
How about they all lived happily ever after?
Is that good?
Yes, my good goose.
That's a good ending.
Lily Lizardson would ask Chicken Little about sunbathing...
...and proper precautions to avoid sun damage.
This will help.
Oh my gosh, Chicken Little!
Thanks so much.
And Turtle Thompson would ask Chicken Little for help...
...when he couldn't think of a rhyme for his raps.
Change the color of his head to red.
Nothing really rhymes with orange.
Ha ha, that's brilliant!
Thanks Chicken Little.
Chicken Little always had a solution for everything.